in the tv show ted lasso this 26
000 seat stadium is filled to the brim
but this shot it was created during the
covet 19 pandemic
now pause and zoom in here see this
woman
she's not really here
[Music]
in fact she was shot on a completely
different continent
in this shot the majority of these
people aren't even real
the ted lasso team pushed the boundaries
on how they could safely fill out the
stands
and knowing all the different ways these
crowds were made could change the way we
see
large crowds in movies and tv forever
[Music]
the largest crowd scene ever shot was
for the movie gandhi which holds the
guinness world record for
most film extras with this funeral
procession reportedly made up of 300
000 real marchers but directing this
many extras
is expensive not to mention a huge
logistical challenge
so movies have turned to using fake
people like this painted matte backdrop
in 1959's ben
hur or these inflatable extras in 2006's
glory road
which are an easy way to give more real
life depth to a fake crowd in the
distance
but fake crowds also come with their own
limitations
they can save the crew money and
properly fill an arena but they can't
move or interact on their own like real
people
so the ted lasso team decided to use a
combination of real
and fake people to make their crowds
look as realistic as possible
barnstorm vfx had two big problems to
deal with
first because of the pandemic they
couldn't fill the stands with as many
real people as they normally would
plus they weren't permitted to film on
the field at the real selhurst park
stadium which the fictional nelson road
stadium is based on
so how did they get all these people to
fill 26
000 seats they constructed an entire cg
stadium and used a technique
called plate extras filming real people
the crew can direct
is best for capturing distinct gestures
up close
like this moment in ted lasso where the
fans lift their fingers and shout a very
specific curse word at ted
let's give it a shot plate extras are
filmed in front of a green screen
and then digitally scattered into the
desired shots the extras are filmed in
an array of costumes while doing a wide
range of movements
oftentimes a set of actions that sort of
flows into one another like
cheer is gonna flow into a boo standing
up sitting down
a typical plate shoot might involve well
over 100 extras but because of lockdown
rules
barnstorm could only use around 20
people members of its own team in los
angeles
but social distancing didn't hurt the
production plate extras aren't filmed
next to each other normally
but further apart than they would be in
a real crowd that way they can be placed
more easily in the final shot
these plate extras were also filmed from
multiple angles
we shot head-on front 45
and then a full profile angle because we
knew
that we weren't going to see people from
behind in this scene the majority of
extras from this angle were actually on
set
but this guy here another extra who was
shot separately because
according to deming the production team
didn't like these two empty seats here
so we did like the smallest crowd
edition we've ever done
it was a high angle we couldn't just
shoot someone head-on on a green screen
i had to estimate the angle and say oh
what lens do we think this was shot on
what do we think the camera height was
get up on a ladder shoot down look at
the shot
compare it still deming couldn't shoot
as many plate extras as he had hoped so
they only made up a small portion of the
crowd
and substituting in green screened
people is never as good as having people
on set
so when that's possible a production
might choose a technique called
crowd tiling basically the crew shoots
one small group and physically moves
them around the set
they're then combined together in
post-production this is how the ted
lasso crew created part of the backdrop
behind jamie here
you can also see an example of this
technique in insecure
where issa and her friends go to a
concert in season 3
episode 5. take a look at this overhead
shot of hundreds of concert goers
in reality there was a group of fewer
than 200 extras on the field
in five separate shots that group is
placed in the left right
center and back of the venue and
rotoscoped together into one shot
crowd tiling is key if you're dealing
with varied lighting as you can see in
the finished shot the crowds in the
front
the middle and the back are all being
hit with different color lights
and a lot of work has to be done to hide
the duplication your eye is very good at
catching duplication
when you're not careful about how you do
crowd tiling
you can literally end up with the same
people
next to themselves these tiles that
formed this one shot from insecure took
an
hour and a half total to shoot and ended
up on screen for only one second
and this technique really only works
when you have stationary shots
you only have that one angle you can't
move the camera during it
it literally just works for the one
angle that you shot it from for ted
lasso the limited amount of real extras
both on set
and in front of a green screen left the
crew a few head-on shots for tiling so
how did they manage to get the stands to
look so full in shots like this
digital doubles a method that's less
realistic up close
but can be used to fill in gaps from a
distance digital doubles made up an
estimated
90 percent of the show's crowd shots the
less detailed doubles came
from a template but productions can
create more detailed ones by scanning
real actors
like margot robbie and i tonya this
technique is the most versatile of them
all
doubles can be re-lit and shot from any
angle plus you can make more unique
characters
deming knew the ted lasso games were
largely shot in the evening
this meant dressing the doubles for cold
weather in cg scarves hats and jackets
because they're completely cgi
characters
we can control everything about their
appearance
unlike matte extras and inflatable
dummies you can also make digital
doubles move and react to the action in
the scene
in ted lasso different sections of the
crowd sometimes needed to have two
reactions at once
since two teams would be playing each
other so they used a crowd simulator
software called golem
here the software is identifying 90 of
the available seats in this section of
the stadium filling it with
angry front-facing fans dressed in the
home team's colors
the same programming that allows us to
assign them a particular color
shirt for example also allows us to
assign them a particular
reaction during this shot where afc
richmond scores a goal
any digital double wearing the red and
blue of that team was programmed to
cheer
because we have this control the entire
crowd
simulation essentially knows we can
categorize them as being on this side
it still needs to feel like a real human
movement as opposed to a faked movement
so barnstorm's animators donned motion
capture suits and fed every movement to
the software and the hardest action
clapping two cg hands going in for a
clap will naturally want to intersect
with one another
and the suit alone couldn't capture
everything oftentimes you'll end up in
this situation where just imagine trying
to clap without moving your wrists and
without moving your fingers
you end up with people doing this sort
of like a seal
you know like the the seal clapping for
their food
so the animators also wore separate
mocap gloves
a relatively recent innovation in the
industry to perfect the complex hand
movements
the key to faking a realistic crowd like
they did in ted lasso
is to combine these techniques into a
cohesive whole
i think my preferred method of creating
a crowd is anything that works
you're not restricting yourself to one
method so the audience is never gonna
quite catch on even if they think they
know what you're doing
oh my god that's a soccer ball and a
goal i'm sorry i'm
freaking excited yes
you